hello everyone and welcome to uh well a
really crazy attacking game that ended
very abruptly from the final round of
day three of the earth things masters
2022 it's magnus carlsen versus
youngsters of duda uh well it's just uh
just a very short wonderful game so
let's dive straight into it and to
better uh maybe understand why magnus
went for such an aggressive setup right
from the start uh he lost the previous
game to eric hansen due to a mouse slip
he was very angry he had to resign and
well maybe that's why he shows such uh
such a crazy opening so here we have e4
by magnus c5 duda goes for the sicilian
defense and now knight to c3 going for
the close sicilian or closed if black uh
you know wishes to keep it uh closed if
you for example goes knight to c6 grabs
full control over the d4 square we're
we're gonna have a hard time playing d4
but here duda goes for g6 and he's
saying i'm up for a very aggressive game
uh the four by magnus c captures and now
as there is no knight on f3 queen
captures on d4 attacking the rook
already so knight to f6 and now bishop
to e3 uh e5 is a bit uh premature here
because knight c6 attacks the queen and
the
pawn and now you can't really you don't
really have a good square for the queen
to defend the pawn if you play queen c5
then you uh invited the bishop to attack
the queen if queen here then ig4 and
then we're gonna pick up the pawn this
way so it's just very bad so instead
after knight to f6 bishop to e3 by
magnus and now knight to c6 attacking
the queen so queen d2 blue white is
playing a standard setup against this uh
well against these dragon like positions
we're going to play f3 castles queenside
king b1 uh bishop h6 trade off the dark
square bishops g4 h4
and so on we're gonna attack the the
black king side this way so the six by
duda with f3 and now uh bishop to e6 uh
and the d7 are known moves here but here
uh duda place a bishop to g7 and it's
already now as of move seven that we
have a completely new game uh we have
knight g to e2 awaiting move by magnus
waiting for duda to decide what to do
with the light squad bishop and maybe
safest here is just to develop the queen
maybe queen a5 maybe a6 b5 uh moves like
that but duda goes for this bishop to d6
idea it's uh uh it's uh i i guess a very
standard here maybe you can play some
like a6 b5 rook c8 knight to e5 again
gain control over the c4 square maybe
then shift the bishop to c c4 yes you're
blocking your e pawn for the moment but
it's not as important uh so uh the other
thing is you give a white this very uh
annoying tempo with knight to f4
attacking the bishop but the duda
actually wanted this he just castles he
says you are welcome to capture here
because if you capture i then get a very
strong center here as you can see i get
a semi-open file for my rook and we're
gonna have a nice game probably um
castles on opposite sides of the board
it's gonna be a very very uh crazy game
but instead magnus starts with h4 as
yasser would say black made his home
address known already so it's time to
you know pay him a visit
and now knight to e5 continuing with
this plan we have h5 by magnus just
going straight for the black king bishop
to c4 offering a trade and now h
captures and g6 and already uh here uh
pretty much everyone plays h captures
and g6 this is an automatic because you
want to capture towards the center and
you're just very very used um
to doing this because uh well the h7
pawn will be a target at some point but
sometimes it's just better to capture
with the f pawn there are very very good
reasons for this and this is one such
case but here uh duda played h captures
on g6 and now the position is completely
winning for magnus but you have to find
one a very uh particular move so feel
free to pause the video here and figure
out a win here for white while i give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on uh finding this
brilliancy and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is of course a
move with the night back so knight to d3
uh congratulations to everyone who found
this the idea is we want to get bishop
to h6 in as soon as possible without
giving black uh even a a move to try and
defend this and now uh it's pretty much
uh
pointless uh to continue this with black
or rather whatever black plays our our
plan is the same just a bishop h6 trade
over the bishops queen to h6 and deliver
checkmate to the black king so how can
do the stop this he goes back with the
bishop uh it's a it's a good try but it
will not be enough bishop to h6 going
for this trait now comes knight the h5
but we of course as soon as we see this
we know that rook captures an h5 is
happening we've seen this so many times
there's even the the that famous video
of bobby fischer i don't know if you've
seen it why you should not play the
dragon with black because uh he says
white just plays the queen d2 bishop e3
pushes g4 g uh h4 sacrifices the rook on
h5 and the black is just busted and this
is pretty much um well exactly as bobby
described it here bishop captures and g7
king captures or if knight captures then
we just play queen h6 and then you get
checkmated so we can't play that so king
captures and now of course rook captures
an h5 right away g captures and now we
have to be very careful we don't want to
play queen g5 and allow black this
defensive resource of knight to g6 so
before delivering this check we just
capture the knight knight captures on e5
do the captures otherwise he's just down
material and now queen g5 check king h7
queen captures an h5 check king to g8
and now bishop to d3 and with this
beautiful developing move uh
that is move 20 it was in this position
uh that youngshish do that resigned to
the game and there is nothing more to be
done here the king is completely
helpless here uh just let's say one
check king goes to the h file any king
move and then rook to h1 will be
checkmate we can even castle deliver
checkmate this way or maybe if if black
really wants to try hard this maybe
queen b6 going for queen to e3 maybe
some f6 queen g5 ideas but uh we can
even castle and just laugh in black's
face
because after this check king b1 let's
say f6 it's still going to be a nice
checkmate here for example rook to h1
and now after we give up all of the
pieces it's just going to be checkmate
so this is only one of the lines but all
the other lines end in checkmate as well
uh so after bishop to d3 duda resigned
and what uh what a very nice victory for
magnus to bounce back into the
tournament after that uh mouse slip
incident against eric hansen uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
sorry i couldn't show more games today i
was very very busy but do use hashtag
suggestion as usual and i will go
through the games that you guys
suggested and try and show as many of
them as possible uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it i would
like to thank anwar the 95 american flag
newman david kimura doug reynolds evan
sterling and pp poopoo for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and i will
see you soon continuing the coverage of
this incredible event
until it finishes
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day